You are just the sweetest.
My little puppy.
Okay, so I'm Miley and I'm chilling with BuzzFeed.
But more importantly, not more importantly but kind of, I'm playing with puppies.
This is the only way I do interviews these days.
I tell my rider I require puppies.
You love me.
Sorry, baby.
Want to pick one?
Okay, we're going to be answering some fan questions.
You can sit on my lap.
You want to eat my ring?
There you go, okay, what does being younger now mean to you?
Well, just like these puppies, all I want to do is be with my family...
...and be with my friends and know what's important, which is being happy.
You want to pick all the questions, don't you?
Okay, I can't, this is the worst way to have me do an interview.
I'm not leaving without this angel.
Okay, next.
Which song from Younger Now is the most special to you?
Malibu was the first song that I wrote on this record so it's extra special to me.
This was my favorite interview I've ever done ever in the history of my life...
...for obvious puppy reasons.